[Music]
hello river babes and welcome to this
special live preview episode of sweet
water secrets celebrating the season
three premiere of Riverdale it's finally
here you guys I've got my jacket I'm so
excited
I'm your host Leonid Galera and I'm
coming to you from our brand new
Sweetwater secrets set I hope you like
it because my amazing crew and I put a
lot of love into this so let me know
what you think now this episode is going
to be sweeter than one of pops
milkshakes not only will I be answering
your fan questions I'm also bringing you
exclusive scoop on what's coming up for
all the ships in season three plus I
have a few surprise interviews from the
Riverdale cast that you definitely don't
want to miss so start sending me your
questions and comments and let's get
started on the biggest preview episode
we've ever done
first up Chelsea Silva asked me how
intense is the episode gonna be oh girl
you better brace yourself because
tonight's premiere is our best one yet
get ready for some fireside romance
shocking supernatural ish twists and one
leading lady steals the show twice next
up Gossip Girl asks does Kevin get some
screen time and my answer is yes but not
as much as he deserves
Kevin Keller is iconic and beyond
reproach and I need much more from him
and Josie this year moving along at
juggy Betty tweeted me and asked how
well hashtag bug head navigate being
serpent royalty what a great question
and you know what I just so happened to
be with Lilly Reinhardt earlier this
week in New York so I'll go ahead and
let her answer that one for me
take a look Lily how does Betty take on
her new role as the queen of the
serpents alongside Jughead so I think at
the end of season 2 when you see Chuck
had to ask her to be his queen you know
I don't it's not like she's gonna wear a
crown on her head like next to Jughead
on a throne but I think it was more so
just a metaphorical sort of title like
hey I want you to be a leader with
I think it was him saying that he wanted
them to be partners in this and that he
acknowledges her as a serpent and you
know she's passed all the tests she's
shown her loyalty to them and I think
that's just kind of what it represents
it's not really her wearing other
jackets all the time and calling herself
a serpent necessarily I think it's just
his way of showing his appreciation for
her and all that she's done for the
serpents and saying like you are you are
officially a member and I'll just add
that Betty has one line tonight that
will make all her serpent subjects
beyond proud next up she boo whom asked
this Cheryl has more screen time in is
she a part of the mystery because she's
the only one keeping the show going
preach now I cannot tell you if Cheryl
will be part of the season three mystery
you'll have to tune in but I can tell
you that she's becoming a very strong
asset for the serpents and that she and
Tony act like a couple queens in the
premiere and Molly Lucas said oMG I
can't wait do you think that arching
Veronica will still be together after
what Hyrum did to Archie also I love
your show and I watch it all the time
and also do you think that there will be
more Shaunie scenes oh thanks so much
for watching Molly and thank you for
asking so many couples questions because
now is the time for me to fill you in on
what's next for each of the current
ships and our Riverdale romance rundown
that's a pretty new graphic now I called
up Riverdale showrunner Roberto
aguirre-sacasa and asked him to tell me
what's to come for each of Riverdale's
perfect pairings and first up is bug
head Roberto said quote bug head is
going to be stronger than ever and
they're gonna be working together after
season two that found them on separate
storylines it's gonna be a little bit
back to basics Betty and Jughead are
gonna be working together to solve a
very twisted mystery and for them that's
like an aphrodisiac like there's nothing
more romantic to Betty and Jughead
then when they're crime-solving together
so we're gonna find them in a good place
for a bit first big chunk of episodes
as for Shoni well we finally get more
screen time from them this year I made
sure to ask and the EP answered
definitely they're an iconic couple that
was forged during season two and the
actors have such an easy rapport to
gather I think we're gonna see Cheryl
and Tony enjoying themselves while
getting into their own capers as well
Cheryl has love in her life for the
first time and it's nice and romantic I
love hearing that
and what about phallus and that sultry
bedroom scene that we all saw in the
season 3 trailer Roberto told me quote
phallus is ascending yes stay tuned for
episode 3 honestly skeet and machen are
the biggest phallus shippers on the
planet what's funny is that we put them
in a scene together in bed and we
basically said now remember there's tons
of storyline points to get in there so
don't make it all about being sexy and
adorable and it's like the sexiest scene
we've ever had on Riverdale and I think
they look incredible um the sexiest
scene we've had on Riverdale I stand and
what about our Riverdale diva Josie
McCoy he said quote in Episode one we're
gonna find out that Josie had a summer
fling and in the first chunk of the
season Josie is gonna be finding what
her song and what her artist voices we
do have a big romance plan for Josie but
we're delaying it for a little bit and
you know what the Pussycats already out
of the bag
Josie's summer fling was with Sweet Pea
do we like them together tell me now
last week I asked you river babes to
vote in the poll for the official
shipper name of kevin and moose and the
winner is drumroll Nevin I like it so
what's next for these two fellas Roberto
said quote I love those guys and I think
they're pretty sexy together and have a
good chemistry and we see them together
in episode 1 and then in episode 2 we
see the differences between them Kevin
is out and moose is not and we kind of
see that that creates a little bit of
friction they're gonna be kissing for a
while I think and last but certainly not
least let's get the scoop on virtue
Roberto was really honest with me and
told
we quote listen they are in trouble
Archie is facing potential time in juvie
hall and very early on there's gonna be
a question of if
Archie goes away are Archie and Veronica
gonna break up I think both of them are
really really crazy about each other and
are in love with each other and I think
neither of them wants that to happen so
they're gonna fight against that and
they're going to fight to stay together
as hard as they can but there are going
to be certain realities that you just
can't kind of work around don't be sad
barchi fans let me cheer you up because
here's a new video of KJ APPA talking
about the red-hot passion that Veronica
and Archie's still share take a look
speaking of hot KJ let's talk about
Archie the couple who has the most PDA I
think that of all the others on the show
they do a daddy don't they yeah look at
you cheese it's coming ahead for you
this year um not too much actually I
think you know their relationship was
definitely put to the test this season
yeah put to the test while they were in
the shower I was bleeding to death in
the hospital right I'm bleeding to death
in the hospital he's got a little blood
on him says we all we all thought that
was kind of strange on the day - shower
scene in the season 2 premiere was good
but the marching moment in the season 3
premiere might just stop it now I've got
a few more questions that I'm going to
answer
Alexia Anders said will chip come back
so he can get his revenge interesting
that you should ask that Alexia because
I also asked Roberto the very same
question so have we seen the last of
chick roberto answered with a simple no
and when I pressed him for more details
he said quote that's all I can say but
that's a lot the fact that we haven't
seen the last of chick I haven't said
that to anyone else okay alright I'm
happy that I'm the only one he told that
to so this is a Sweetwater secrets
exclusive but I'm not happy that chicks
coming back he's the worst
and finally Brian Alexander commented
yay
so happy Sweetwater secrets we'll be
back soon and Riverdale season is back
again are there any easter eggs to the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina in season
three O'Brien
I loved that you asked this because
number one there will be Easter eggs and
number two
I've got some exciting news for you all
if you love sweet water secrets and are
exciting for the chair excited for the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina then
you'll definitely want to tune in to the
upcoming episodes of my brand new series
the witches council Wicked's coming
witches now this is all I can show you
for now but keep them locked to my
Twitter page for more details as we get
closer to the premiere of Sabrina now
I'm gonna take a look at some of the
comments you've been leaving me
throughout this episode there have been
so many first of all I see that there's
so many Shoni fans out there
hi Queens yes we're all in this together
Amelia says will it be straight-up
horror I mean there are moments that are
gonna make you jump I'm just gonna tell
you that it's it's not so much horror
but it gets dark this year you guys
Judith says what is the leader what is
the name of the leader of the farm his
name is Edgar ever never and he has a
daughter named Evelyn ever never and you
will meet her in Episode two and she's
just haunting so stay tuned for that
Ruby says is Cheryl blossom scaling the
show as usual wait until you see
Cheryl's entrance in season 3 I just
okay Millie says do we get to see more
of the side characters get more time
like Chuck and Reggie um we haven't seen
Chuck so far Reggie's around but I'm not
quite sure I'm still focusing on we need
a little bit more Kevin and Josie
everyone else will have their time
Jolene says will we know what was in
that letter FP wrote for Alice I'm not
answering that one you'll have to stay
tuned randy says you are beautiful I
love your red serpent jacket will Betty
ever get a pink one first of all hi
Randy secondly I asked Lilly Reinhardt
if she wants Betty to get a pink serpent
jacket and I will tell you right now
I will play that answer for you it's
amazing in next week's preview episode
so next Wednesday come back here I'm
gonna have that exclusive answer for you
it's pretty epic Laura Delaney says how
will they add in the supernatural I have
answers on that after tonight's episode
from Roberto because it's gonna seem
like the show is leaning into the
supernatural because of Sabrina I've got
all the answers just stay tuned it's
kind of confusing um let's see Jessica
Joyce says Wilfred died oh my god I hope
not
he's already been shot and we've had to
worry about this as an entire time if
Fred dies I'm gonna leave I won't but
let's be real Jesse says was Clifford
blossom actually a real blossom I think
so I don't think we have any reason as
to why he wouldn't be what I want to
know is is his twin brother gonna be
making another appearance because he's
the worst Veronica X Lodge says bar
cheese fans are very thankful for any
information we get and with a heart
emoji that's very nice of you honestly I
have high hopes for virtue this year
they were super super strong together in
season two so naturally it's a
television show it seems like this is
gonna be the year that they are tested
so we're just gonna all have to hang in
there we did see in the promo that
Veronica says we are endgame and if you
tune into tonight's after-show so it'll
be posted tomorrow you're gonna notice
something very important that has been
almost left out of the episode and I'll
have exclusive answers from Roberto
explaining what happened so just a
couple more um oh gosh I hope I don't
mess up your name I'm really sorry
Rishabha Condor II will check return and
will cause havoc yes he will return as
we just revealed and all the rest of
these comments are just so amazing we're
gonna end it right now because I've been
talking for a really long time but there
you have it thank you all so much for
tuning in to this special live preview
episode of Sweetwater secrets but don't
you worry I'll be back on your screens
tomorrow with our special after-show
episode for the season 3 premiere of
Riverdale that is packed with exclusive
dance
from the cast and from the creator
Roberto aguirre-sacasa now in the
meantime if you need my Riverdale in
your life check out our special how to
throw a Riverdale party video to find
out how to throw a party that even
Jughead would enjoy but for now leave me
your comments below about all the
shipper scoop I just gave you how are
you feeling about virtue what are you
most concerned about in season 3 do you
like the new Sweetwater set because I
love it
and I will be seeing you guys every
single Wednesday and Thursday all season
long for even more Sweetwater secrets
thank you guys so much for tuning in I'm
Leon Aguilera and I love you river babes
so much
[Music]
you